哈喽朋友们 欢迎收看三十次游动机一天吃什么了
早上第一顿必须是书果陆
我在东千喝的书果陆和夏天会有点吃别
在东千我会用温水去打
然后里面会多放一些江黄肉贵铃铃铃
就是这种非常暖的粉丝
就不会很含量
这一杯的精水就在于我在里面放了一些夏微果
所以它喝起来会有一些奶味哦
很好和大肯试试
而且它虽然是温味的
但口感很好不会让大家认为这些
这个喝点是温味的
一般这一杯喝完我就要去测索了
非常非常通常的
那现在刚在我们熬里的早餐啊
那你还没吃早餐呢是不是
然后过来过来过来
这个小朋友
逃级点力又很挑食
什么十两都不吃
所以我一般早晚都会给它吃这种泡水洞干
你是想吃这个
脱肉等呢
还是要吃这个生股肉
于想要的呀
脱肉脱肉
真棒 好脱肉
五个
它只会把这个水都吃了完了之后
才能把这个洞干给吃进去
它我会直接从水里面把洞干掉出来
不问了屁然它多喝点水
里面就小猫咪
它很容易变密
光盼了
昨天晚上会太晚了
没有洗头
现在洗头
我中午点的椰子机外卖
我发现椰子机除了好多新款
以前吃只有什么
煮鲜椰子机
现在什么流连的秋梨蛋
我点的是鲜果椰子机
里面有无花果
木瓜
人生果玉米铃子什么的
很好吃很清爽
我已经爱上了
我最近调好几次
椰子机和水果的搭配很奇妙
广东人吃
今天真的是有一套
每一次吃这个椰子机里面的
饭
我都要饭
这个料
网里面的椰子
胡椒人就太胜痛
不价这个价格的话
它都会很淡
很香
一般吃完午饭
我就会开始吃我的内部了
还是第三家鱼肉加胡鱼
每天来一大目东
儿ly 周五吃什么
她的鱼有
你就好
看来今天真的是很像是
每次就是把这个鱼有几道
就动干一上涨再让它吃下去
不然单独的鱼油它不会吃
它自从吃的鱼油之后三个月了
它现在真的不怎么叫毛了
我一打开门
加门口对了好多快递养
有了快递着咱起来
到时候给大家拍开箱
但是像小零食这种
我是真的赞不了一点的
准备
拆平锅手机了
我想要拍拿着产品
然后能看见我的那个双镜头的那个
视频可以买了这个
直接打开之后就
套上咱们的
手机可来的
早上的那个早餐
这个红薰火都给我弄了半个
然后还有半个红薰的吃了
这个材物株干我是看愿然的视频推荐的
真的还蛮好吃的很购味
而且它居然是我老家生产的
两段那么购味
晚上会朋友約了吃饭
我发现我不是和那种很明昐的原则
这种第一宝和的豆沙呀
煙粉熟悉饭而比较适合我
O.T.D整式准备出门楼
现在先去接我朋友
出饭
我们晚上要去舍口吃一家
超火的同锅善仰肉
我来了一锅呀
没事
它排队我们五点多钟就到了
我的战略就是
什么都放一点
让我这个虎耐人平时吃火锅的话
我是完全受不了放麻酱和服务的
但是吃羊肉的话
我一定会加和羊肉真的是橘配
其实有东西是要少吃羊肉的
但我都要先吃羊肉的
所以偶尔罪餐
想吃也不会那么容易长度
他们家的羊肉真的蛮好吃的
就很新鲜
很够味
尤其是这个牛肉烧味
哇 刚刚真出来
真的好觉
肉烧卖
哇 好好吃
没让你吃
而且新鲜比真的很高
我们两个人吃群厚的话
才吃了200块钱不到
时刻这边真的是有很多很多
好吃的
可以说是我的美食物脱帮
我差不多每周都会来一趟时刻
来吃美食
吃完了火锅
现在去吃一个棉莓
你羊肉店大概走路
也就五分钟不到吧
他们家的棉莓
用的是水牛奶
就能吃出来
不是那种加了奶
已经的味道
而且它家的棉莓
没有那么容易换
很杀识
玉尼蒂蒂的
我这次点的是新品草
没味的
我觉得还是没有他们家
招牌忙活的好吃
我就发现
如果以后是
带朋友去品上
不仅喜欢的
美食的时候
还是不要点自己
都没吃过的
经验之态
吃完棉莓
才8点多钟
我们就准备
去深圳外喝点小酒
去开车的时候发现
妈呀
我新喜的车上有
好多厚多的
小猫咪的小脚银
不知道是哪一只小猫咪
这么有眼光
我看这一排
只有我的车上有
我2020年的心爱
好就是
喝点小酒
是不是跟朋友
小卓一杯
它一开心了
是我皮肥生活中的调味级
清好皮不才会好
回家了
第一时间
先喝个小猫
好吗
然后呢
喝点小猫
小铃银时
中了一会儿
大细了的睡觉了
视频
就到这里了
第一次排我老个希望
大家会喜欢
拜拜